I have never seen that done in my life
squat was for Highness when I see
frazzles I'm not even interested -
what's in that no these are amazing what
do I love about frazzle I piss all me
snacks on a shiny they make your fingers
and these your fingers are glowing after
these the best thing about these as well
you can lick your fingers for it I was
after and you can still taste rim flakes
this - this to me is a prawn cracker
small prawn cracker Oh authentic it on
that are fragile though there's some
appraisals all day long bought in the
sort of hums across the water
international friendship and we're for
that well gesture I'm sticking with a
frozen yeah
shrimp legs yeah yes this store is a bit
of me know that what did you call it is
a kid I am Bruce I'm saying I am Bru
it's no it's called earn brew you right
there's no oh no not I used to always
call it I am brave my mind is blonder
I've never seen brew did not even spot
brew correctly what's that grass jelly D
Chang well have a little smell it's like
nothing I've ever smelled
the thing what I do like it is that
yours
can't be anything but from yours the
coming years
Cheers tell you what that's all right
cool did the one thing you might find a
bit odd when you drinking it liquid
comes to your mouth but the cam feels
heavy like there's something else in
there I think I'm the bottom really
every widget it's something heavy in
there you go
no one Pleasant no it's still not the
grass jelly drink oh really that I want
some ham
[Laughter]
I have never seen that done in my life
squat ones for highness
that is right well there's your answer
on that amazing there's nothing on that
where I want you're not seeing the
cherry very well you're from one kiss
your laughs you don't like cherry very
well yeah that's like someone said they
don't like breathing here we go I work
the ice a little bit over here sir he's
wife cakes that could be anything
is it me is it recommends pine it smell
could be my fingers Oh Cheers very well
I don't like to tell you about even like
cherry they closer than that these wood
it was alive have a look oh oh no I
reckon this is all you've got in on that
nobody's first released well I'm gonna I
need to get one of these in my mouth
first second oh that scared me breath
away huh
not sure
neither for me online know if you had to
have one of them if I had two of what
I'd sooner have an onion than a tentacle
I've got to be honest yeah
no I'm not gonna do after that actually
tastes nicer typical you know it's just
a fad Lisa tentacled brought me mine
this is patty I'm Fred and this is snap
Wars Milan's Bible get me ready
[Applause]
that's a man's man ready Flynn talk
about wife kids don't mean